i want to talk to you guys about the
fake news cause this is uh this is a
really funny story and we have the
ability to debunk it um we have the
story from the times dot co dot uk
quote just like a mob meeting what
trump's curious golf course can fabs
that's tongues wagging what was this
donald trump having a secret meeting on
a golf course with no golf clubs i
wonder who was at the secret meeting
well newsweek reports something about uh
rumors that those who joined trump of
the course of course were minority
leader kevin mccarthy of fox news sean
hannity and former congressman turned
ceo of truth social devin nunes wait a
minute done well that's just rumors what
about this
raw story correction a previous version
of the story alleges that devin nunes
kevin mccarthy oh okay all right well
what about this daily dot you know the
daily dot just points out with a with a
tweet they don't actually state it
themselves
he has been he has not been photographed
golfing he's photographed with mccarthy
nunes eric trustee hannity and others
standing in the rain on a golf course
with no clubs and no golf shoes
apparently that tweet was enough to get
raw story to report that it was a fact
and for newsweek to run the rumor that
these people were there
this would have to mean
mr nunes that you can in fact teleport
yes actually i'm i'm there if you look
in the tree see that picture there in
the tree and the tree if you just look
behind there
yeah you can't there yeah yeah yeah
that's me yeah that's it yeah yeah so
see they were close but wrong so um this
is funny because this story went viral
they claimed all these people were there
you weren't there
no in fact it was it was so i was
actually commuting from california back
back east and i was actually headed to
washington dc
and i had a long delay in dallas
at the dallas airport it got you know
like everybody's getting now but i ended
up supposed to be there two hours i was
there like six hours so you're in dallas
um how did you feel when you found out
you were actually in dc on a golf course
well that's at night all of a sudden my
phone blows up with these stories
and then i'm like what in the hell is
this
and then i'm reading and i don't even
know what the hell is going on and i'm
trying to get you know i'm trying to get
on and then i get on the airplane and
then and then i fly and then i don't get
into washington until like it was
actually 2 30 when i landed
a.m
and then the next morning my phone is
blowing up i'm like what in the hell is
this
so yeah i was clearly right there in
those trees yeah so i was i could i was
at in dallas and there at the same time
magical well people need to understand
that the issue is if you if you jumped
from dallas to dc then the paladins
would track you down um
tracing your jump scar and uh you know
be very dangerous for for jumpers like
devon what's that from it's from jumper
okay okay
who can teleport yeah i wonder who got
that reference hayden christensen i
think was in it he was the main guy
right i don't know that movie i was
thinking of the the dude from the x-men
that could teleport morph no no not more
night crawler what i think morph why did
i say that yeah he was a good character
by the way i don't know he only made it
in like a couple of the x-men movies
nightcrawler yeah oh yeah yeah his fight
scene in x-men 2 was awesome fighting
and teleporting at the same time yeah so
this is amazing but he like disappeared
like he's not he he wasn't in the
last
the last movies
i is he not in it they rebooted it and
he saw him like i think he might be you
know come yeah he's a good character are
they gonna bring him back i have no idea
well did you know colonel harvey is like
a nightcrawler too oh yeah that's right
that's right yeah because you guys were
able to this was a bigger jump you went
from uh for from where from italy or
from where were you we were uh
we were meeting dirty russians and
ukrainians and where were we
vienna where in vienna wow
so okay yes
so the media claims
the story's still up by the way you can
go to cnn the story's up i'm not not
making this up you can and the crazy
left believes it yep it's still up it
hasn't been taken down it's blue and on
there it is oh is this one the giuliani
associate willing to tell congress noona
has met with ex-ukrainian official get
dirt and biden yep that's the one this
is this is amazing it's amazing
these journalists don't bother asking
you they just run it i mean i'm saying
that's more rhetorically i don't know if
they literally called you over this but
i've dealt with stories
what happens is
one journalist will write a fake story
they'll wait 15 minutes and then redact
they'll stealth edit it but by then all
the other outlets will have already
picked it up and take plausible
deniability and say
we weren't uh there's no actual malice
we were just repeating what you know nbc
or what this other outlet said yeah so
we assumed it was true i would love to
go to vienna austria i've never been
there ever well we know we know this so
so this story actually
so these guys so i i sued cnn
and they skated right and so the fake
news will report that i lost this
lawsuit but they what they do is they
use technicalities and so they they got
a judge
to agree
that even though this all occurred and
it impacted me in washington dc
you know with intelligence overseas
and how they got out of it is they said
that no california law applied and i
didn't do my retraction notice in time
that's how they got out of this that's
why that story is still alive cnn's
california based
no no no
unprecedented never been done before
california a judge ultimately got
transferred the case got long story but
it got transferred to new york in a in a
new york judge democrat appointed judge
said for the first time that i know of
that california law applies to me even
though i was a federal official chairman
of the house intelligence committee in
washington
that's how they get out of it it's not
just that it's that the story is that
giuliani associate is willing to tell
congress that you did this and they're
like well that's a factual statement it
doesn't mean it actually happened it
means someone is willing to say it
happened that is
you wanna know how it works i love that
i love this you'll get a story and it'll
say source close to nancy pelosi's
office claims that you know she's
planning to meet with vladimir putin or
donald trump or something and then
people go oh wow oh wow a source close
to her office and the source close to
her office is a homeless guy sleeping in
the alley he is close to her office that
was all true can't sue him for fake news
because it's literally the truth well
this is an affirmative defense the funny
thing about this guy is though the this
guy
these cnn and these reporters so this is
a guy named uh pornos harness parnasse
who who you know he he had tried to like
so so colonel harvey was my investigator
right so when people would have you know
when they would have things that they
want us to look at and you know we would
take all comers right so derek would
have to meet everyone well this guy came
to us and said oh he had all kinds of
information of course he didn't have
anything
and so derek met with him a couple times
and then this guy he was described by
cnn as a wolf in sheep's clothing so
they know he's a he's a liar he's now in
jail by the way yeah he's now in jail
and this guy went on and the democrats
would repeat this garbage right about me
about derek and and they knew
so when you talk about teleporting we
were in we were actually it's kind of
funny
uh when we later were able to say this
because i filed it in court we were
actually in libya
so
the so what must have happened is they
leaked that they knew we were on
international travel because we were
traveling on behalf of the government
and we were the first we were the first
delegates someone from hipste leaked it
probably adam shifts people yeah but we
were in we were actually in libya
meeting with half tar pretty damn
dangerous place where in benghazi wow we
were in benghazi and these bastards run
this story and they run this story you
know to to just to just dirty ass up and
they didn't bother asking you
um you know i don't even remember if
they did or not i think they asked for
an interview but but what i do after 17
after 2017 when they accuse me of being
a russian agent like if you accuse me of
being a russian agent
like until you retract that story i
don't talk to you yeah and was like i'm
not going to talk to them and with lev
parnasse i investigated i looked at all
the information made a few inquiries
over a period of like six weeks because
it wasn't constant it's just
intermittent over a period of time
because you've got a lot of stuff going
on and i came to dev and i said this is
a dead end this guy's not trustworthy
and then and then they release this is i
don't know if you guys remember this is
when
schiff released my phone records that's
right and and also john solomon too
right yeah a bunch of people he released
a bunch of phone numbers yeah so
we couldn't you know if you call back in
the day and then this is how all members
of congress i think if they're doing
their job if somebody calls in like if
you were to call in to your
congressman's office
today you know hopefully he would get a
call back within two or three days
and so the port so in this case poor
harvey was you know this guy calls in i
tell harvey to call the guy
and then all of a sudden you know these
phone records are released as if
harvey's now done something bad because
he's just calling somebody back that had
information that said was relevant
that's his job yeah
that's crazy that he he released the
private information of a journalist
yeah how about me his colleague well
yeah yeah no of course of course
but you know how you have john solomon
on by the way no no no no well he's he's
great how was the trip to libya though
right that place isn't really uh known
for its uh international
visitors how would you describe it it
kind of looked like a hellscape a little
surreal
a little surreal i mean slavery it kind
of looked when we landed there there was
like well the russians were on one side
of the airport yeah strong start and um
and then but it did look like i thought
i saw the devil out there with like a
pitchfork and a sign that said welcome
to hell well now
we're working with the russians we
really went to benghazi to work with the
russians how did russia come to be the
the villain you know like is it is it
because of the pipeline it's because of
gaz promise because of ukraine because i
i certainly think china's a bigger thing
they loved russia okay so this is the
this is the dam like everybody asked me
like how did you know
that the russia stuff was was nonsense
it was really easy and of course the
fake news has ignored this the whole
time
so
in
2013 or 12 13 14
russians were pushing obama around
remember i'm on the intelligence
committee um i worked really closely
with with our eastern european allies
like poland and romania and others and
remember the russians like suddenly they
were in libya doing everything suddenly
they were in
syria doing things suddenly they
overtake crimea with little green men so
so i'm involved in all this
and
we couldn't get
the obama administration to do a damn
thing
you know they would not do anything
uh to the
you know to the russians they just
wouldn't deal with them so you can
imagine so in two that in the in the
spring of 2016
and just for your time the time
reference this is when the obama biden
administration are working with the
clinton campaign that begin
investigating trump and republicans to
tie them to russia okay i have no idea
that's going on
but in the spring of 2016
i went out and made which is a really
you know
important statement at the time the
chairman of the house intelligence
committee said look
the biggest intelligence failure since 9
11 is our failure to understand putin's
plans and intentions
so this is the biggest intelligence
fighter since then so i say that at the
same time that they are painting us
with being some kind of russian agent so
you can imagine after the election when
they come and say oh the russians were
trying to help trump in a republican
what the hell are you talking about you
guys haven't done any damn thing about
russia i said this is a lie i've never
seen because i i was actually paying
attention to what putin was doing they
weren't yeah well putin was building his
sphere of influence and alliance with
the syrian government but when barack
obama was in power there was even
serious talks of barack obama
potentially launching an invasion or an
attack on syria and then it was general
flynn that came out and actually
whistleblowed and talked about how the
united states was funding radical
islamists inside of that region and i
think there's been a massive payback
against him for that so there's a lot of
also complicated geopolitical
maneuvers in all of this if you remember
i remember the russians also intervened
and sent their battleships to prevent
u.s warships from being off the coast of
syria from potentially launching more
missile strikes i remember there was
protests there um
what do you remember for that what do
you remember from that time because a
lot of people thought we were very close
to a war with syria i i think you're i
think you're actually missing one of the
most important
uh
data points
do you remember the time that that obama
leaned over before the election when he
was running against mitt romney
and at the time uh he was talking to the
russian president which i can't think of
his name now medvedev
and he said and he's on a hot mic and he
says yeah tell vladimir till i have to
wait till after the election you know or
something like that i'll have more
flexibility more flexibility
yeah i mean that's the biggest issue
collusion
yeah i love the the classification
narrative they're doing now
because the implication is the president
doesn't have the ability to declassify
documents unilaterally
and the point i make is imagine the
president the united states meeting with
the the president of russia
and them saying it's time to negotiate a
de-escalation of these nuclear weapons
and he goes i wish i could but i don't
have the ability to classify what our
weapons are so i can't tell you it's
classified sorry maybe there's some
higher authority in the united states
that can tell me what i'm allowed to
tell you and then we'll negotiate that's
an insane prospect
well that's what we dealt with i mean
that's why
people have to remember in 2017
we knew nearly right away i just went
through the story of how i knew why i
knew i knew they were full of [ __ ] but i
definitely knew
that this was a problem when i found out
that the clinton campaign
you know had paid for this dossier
and you know how long it's crazy you
know how long it took for us to get that
out to the public
we knew that for nine months and you
couldn't release it no if you remember
they were trying to investigate me yeah
remember they put me under an ethics
investigation
remember that they were going after all
of my team all of our lawyers everyone
so they were looking for any way and
remember trump is under investigation by
moeller the mueller witch hunt crew so i
mean they've got an army
of g-men doj
with a special counsel authority i'm
sitting there in congress with under
investigation because they said i was
leaking leaking intelligence it took us
that long to get that information out to
the public and if you go back in time if
you remember that february time frame of
2018 remember they said he's gonna
people are gonna die if nunus releases
this memo it's gonna be horrible and
then like the next day it came out oh
this is no big deal the clinton campaign
everybody knew that
you know
they did the fake news did know that the
clinton campaign but none of us knew the
american public didn't know the
attitudes tim is so similar to remember
vinman when he was testifying and he
basically said that the enemy is the
audience of vineman you got to make
vinman was the lieutenant colonel
whistleblower yeah you know complainer
that led to the ukrainian impeachment
issue and he thought it was so important
that the president was possibly
betraying
you know and doing things that the
interagency didn't want vinman said
that the interagency
dictates what the president should be
doing that's not the president who
determines foreign policy it's the
interagency
yeah that's crazy do you think that
vendeman is a useful idiot or do you
think he's willfully malicious
both both i was going to say an idiot
who's malicious
that's crazy the uh he's not smart
enough to be like he's not very talented
but he's definitely a useful idiot they
wanted him to be the minister of defense
for ukraine
yeah according to him getting ready for
which but that's what shows you as a
useful idiot
those ukrainians they thought here's a
dumb ass that we can bribe let's tell
him that we want him to be the the
uh
joe biden the you know if the
prosecutor's not fired
that that whole thing i mean do you guys
do you guys know stuff that we don't
i've done uh quite a bit of uh
research into the whole ukraine gate
scandal and it really does seem like
right now especially with hunter biden's
laptop
that uh joe biden's involved in illicit
business dealings that he's using his
son as a proxy that's what it seems like
and i have to wonder now with the the
billions that are being dumped into
ukraine is this joe biden paying good on
his debts i knew you were russian asset
that's what i was like oh yeah yeah
you're repeating russian disinformation
yeah i love just real quick i love how
politico reported i think it was in
early 2017 that ukrainian officials
colluded uh to help the democrats win
the election were embarrassed and
scrambling now that donald trump won and
then a few years later their one of
their reporters said actually that story
was russian disinformation yet they
still haven't retracted the initial
report how can your outlet
simultaneously report both things yeah
amazing i mean look they haven't
retracted that report the one that's
still up on on the screen there yeah
real quick yeah burisma timeline i'd
just like to run through it real quick
for you because i think it matters about
the
the call for firing the prosecutor
the white house under under obama
had a conference with ukrainian
officials
in late january
and on the offside of that conference at
the old executive office building they
were addressing corruption and they
asked the state prosecutor
representatives there to back off the
barissimo investigation
a week later
back in ukraine they conducted a raid of
the barisma headquarters and the
president of the barisma company's home
that led to at least eight phone calls
over the next 10 days between
president biden
and president porchenko of ukraine
which then subsequently led to a trip
coordinated by eric charamella
to ukraine
where they put the the hammer down
saying we need the investigation of
barissimo ended they mastered under
corruption saying that the attorney
the state's attorney was corrupt
that's when they threatened
to withhold imf funding that same
prosecutor that they're asking to be
fired for corruption had gotten an award
from the united states at the end of
2015 for being a stellar prosecutor
yeah i mean look if we would have
you know the hunter biden laptop i mean
if if if you and i and your team here
decide tonight
that we're just going to start doing
crack cocaine bringing some prostitutes
or whatever the fbi will be knocking on
your door tomorrow morning
lying on our taxes lying on the
government uh gunfire throwing a gun in
the garbage outside of a school
behind us
that's crazy show some guns here do some
crack and they'll they'll be here in 24
hours thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there